[Music]
just a few years ago it would have been
unimaginable for media companies to
censor political candidates in election
years but now it's commonplace
just this year twitter has censored
several tweets from the sitting
president united states
in one instant twitter the company
accused the president of quote
glorifying violence
glorifying violence his crime he
promised to use force to restore the
rule of law on the streets of washington
d.c
twitter has also routinely used bogus
fact checks to prevent users from
learning that mail-in balloting is a
massive fraud risk
which it is this is yet another example
of election interference far more
profound than anything russia ever did
by american tech companies so what is
the federal government
doing about it federal officials will
tell you a lot about
russia and the threat they pose to our
democracy but no one ever seems to
mention
this lawmakers recently held anti-trust
hearings the president signed an
executive order that could revoke the
special immunity that some tech websites
receive from lawsuits
but none of that's happened yet will
anything happen matt whitaker is the
former acting u.s attorney general he's
the author of the book above the law
he joins us tonight matt whitaker thanks
so much for coming on
so you can imagine and i'm sure you
share the frustration
it's infuriating to watch
large monopolies change the course of
american history by
subverting our elections and no one's
doing anything about it will anyone in
power
do anything to stop this before election
day do you believe
glad to be with you tucker and yes i i
actually do believe
uh that we are going to get to the
bottom of this insidious
really censorship of mostly conservative
voices on social media
and i think the department of justice
has been looking at this issue
and i also believe that because of the
way the algorithms that
facebook and twitter and the like used
to
provide your news feed i think that
could be viewed and and may be viewed by
this department of justice as a
campaign contribution an illegal
campaign contribution
that ultimately i think they will step
in and take action
i mean we've got two months left and
it's really not even a question of
trying to get trump reelected or helping
joe biden i mean i think the
implications are far more profound
and long-lasting than that google
single-handedly could erode any
public confidence in democracy and i
just wonder if people the department of
justice see
this problem in those terms
i think they do and and i think what
what is also happening
among these companies facebook in
particular
they have so much data on their
individual users that they can
essentially
manipulate uh what you see how you see
it and therefore
based on uh their the feedback loop that
is provided they can then try to
influence you to
whether it's use a product vote for a
candidate uh
it's really again it's insidious and i
think the department of justice has to
act because our democracy
can probably not stand this for another
election cycle
i wonder i mean since you're very
familiar with how the federal government
actually works since you ran
our most important agency do you think
it's
fair to say that there are federal
officials
who are afraid to take on google
i i don't think so i think bill barr the
attorney general
uh is not afraid really unafraid of
anything
and ultimately it's what laws and what
tools do we have as
in the executive branch we execute the
law and so you know the
the section 230 of the communications
decency act
provides a safe harbor for these
companies that i think
you know congress uh needs to act and to
provide some relief
so that so that there can be more
enforcement
on that front well that's exactly right
i mean that is a legislative matter they
gave these companies that special carve
out we didn't get it
and they haven't taken it back matt
whitaker thank you for that great to see
you congrats on the book thank you
tucker good to see you